une expérimentation de trois à six mois
vient de débuter à saint lambert des
bois trois radars sonore appelés radars
hydre sont testés et est talonné au
niveau de la rd 46 ils sont fabriqués
par ac om micro db et bruitparif le
principe c'est vraiment de d'identifier
avec précision le niveau sonore des
véhicules à leur passage et lorsque ça x
est d'un certain seuil qu'il n'est pas
encore fixée qu'il le sera pas arrêté
ministériel dans les semaines qui
viennent dans ce cas là on transmettra
le dossier d'infraction c'est le premier
radar ténor avisés de troll sanctions
135 euros damende c'est le prix qu'il
faudra payer en cas d'infraction une
seconde phase de test avec verbalisation
prévus fin 2022
saint lambert des bois fait partie des
trois sites retenus pour cette
expérimentation la vallée de chevreuse
est un lieu bien connu pour ses bruits
de moteurs excessif
[Applaudissements]
en eau sur la d 91 il ya un petit hameau
qui s'appelle labrosse qui est très
impacté par par ce phénomène de bruit il
ya onze mille véhicules qui passent par
jour à cet endroit là plus le week-end
les les motos et les voitures aussi
bruyante la pollution sonore entre
engine chroniques troubles du sommeil
est responsable d'au moins douze mille
décès prématurés chaque année en or